[Musique]
émilie nicolas michel ces objets à la
question gay bonsoir
l'immigration là les chiffres ont été
lancés tous les chiffres ont été lancés
je vous remontre le tableau ce qui
n'était pas avec nous il ya quelques
minutes seuils d'immigration québec
c'est un débat depuis longtemps belle
hausse le débat se précise les gens
donnent leurs cibles parti québécois
aujourd'hui a dit nous c'est à 35000 on
veut revenir
avant l'aller leur char est donc il ya
une vingtaine d'années quand le québec
accueillait à peu près 35 e mail c'est
la capacité selon parti québécois de
d'adaptation des nouveaux immigrants la
caq ces cinq ans veut redescendre à 50
milles jeudi redescend ce
qu'actuellement c'est 70 mille cinquante
mille le parti conservateur de monsieur
duhaime 70 mais les libéraux peut-être
plus la même mais 70 milles et québec
solidaire hier à l'émission nous disait
il le répète aujourd'hui entre 60 et 80
milles
oui ce sont des chiffres mais il ya des
philosophies différentes derrière touche
à tour de table émilie nicolas est ce
que le débat est bien engagée d'abord
d'après vous
1 s'est engagé au sens où avec la nôtre
parti québec aujourd'hui c'est un sujet
dont on
était dans les années dans les années 90
donc c'est sûr que ça suscite un débat
après je pense que la question de fond
pour beaucoup de personnes au québec la
question de la pudeur
et la façon dont ça avec les services
dans un spectre entrepreneurs dont ça a
fait un paquet d'entreprises en
particulier dans les régions du québec
aussi qui a fait que les enfants à la
rentrée donc je pense que la question de
l'immigration pour beaucoup de gens
quand on regarde les chiffres ça peut
être abstrait pour voir c'est quoi des
conséquences de ces chiffres là quand
les gens finissent à laquelle sont dans
les français c'est moins une question
chiffres d'aussi desquels ils migreront
part quels sont les services en
francisation qui sont offerts ou pas
offert dans les différentes régions du
québec donc je pense que c'est que ces
enjeux là qui sont contenus pour les
gens que des chiffres comme ceux qui
sont lancés dans des bas qu'est ce que
ça nous dit michel c'est sur les propres
propositions politiques derrière le
chiffre parce que le chiffre seule chose
mais il ya deux philosophies enfin
presque 3 philosophie là d'un
homme michel ange entend pas
on vous entend pas à nous à l'eau on met
alec michel havard et qu on va vous
allez rallumer votre micro et
je tiens vous entend pas
alec alors même question à l'inconnu
d'abord les différences assez importante
dans les approches malgré les sucres que
vous avez montré parce que vous avez mis
cinquante mille migrants pour le parti
conservateur du québec or ces 4000
immigrés ans parce qu'on le demandait
résume en quelques chiffres il voulait
qu'on mettre parce que pas que politique
d'émigration parti conservateur du
québec et devoirs mettez 50000 si vous
voulez n'a pas d'importance à la ronde
mis un chiffre al'inverse vous dit on
passe de 70 à 50 milles
de retard pendant la pandémie dans les
15 dernières années mise à part un petit
hiatus de deux ans on est toujours entre
50 et 55 mille donc la position de
françois legault est assez pas conforme
à ce que les libéraux avaient avant lui
alors que chez au parti québécois mais
l'on propose une rupture où on est plus
à 50000 145000 comme c'est le cas depuis
presque vingt ans on est vraiment d'en
diminuer le nombre d'immigrants oui une
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre n'y a pas de
corrélation toujours directe entre la
qualité de entre le les cas croissance
économique et l'immigration mais
certains points à nos communes 35000 il
pas mal d'employeurs que vont trouver
que c'est peut-être un creux bord y
compris en région sur léman montréal en
région on a besoin de monde on a besoin
d'avoir de la main d'oeuvre en gaspésie
dans le bas-saint-laurent en abitibi
alors il faudra expliquer le pourquoi on
est capable d'aller
des chiffres aussi bons alors que le
cortex démographique n'est plus celui
des années 90 mais ce qu'on dit et du
côté du parti québécois de la quête dans
une certaine mesure parce qu'on n'est
pas si loin 50 mais sait on ne peut pas
en accueillir davantage parce que c'est
une menace claire à la langue française
c'est seul argumentaire emilie que l'on
présente
mais c'est intéressant comme
argumentaire parce que le principe une
grande langue internationale
donc il ya plein de gens qui parlent de
france et ailleurs dans le monde qui
peuvent souhaiter immigré au québec et
aussi le français est une langue qui
s'apprend donc c'est sûr que même en ce
moment il ya des milliers d'enseignants
même en francisation il ya des files
d'attentes pour les gens qui souhaitent
apprendre le français
elle a dit qu il y aurait moyen de
diversifier c'est un flot de larmes plus
accessible à un plus grand nombre de
personnes y compris souvent des
étudiants étrangers qui dans certains
cas sont exclues de ces coureurs-là donc
un ensemble de choses qu'on peut faire
aussi de ce niveau de ce côté-là il
forme que dans le raisonnement que moi
j'ai entendu hier c'est comme si les
grands sont des gens qui parlent de
français qui n'approuvent pas le
français alors que la réalité bien sûr
et plus complexe que ça donc quand on
dit on peut moins des migrations pour
prat et de la langue française ne veut
pas le message a intérêt que c'est les
personnes qui sont issus de
l'immigration sont des menaces à la
langue française c'est extrêmement
compliqué comme message envoyé surtout
dans la vue la complexité de la société
québécoise où il ya plein de gens qui
oui bien sûr que des gens qui ont bien
plus de france et il ya aussi les
transferts vers l'anglais qui demain
enfin les chiffres montrent que quand
même le français your recul est-ce que
c'est pas un argument qui qui porte sur
alec rebonjour michel chevalet avec vous
après à l'export un argument qui qui
porte dans la population de dire il faut
faire attention autrement dit dit on
bien sûr et je pense que la plupart des
gouvernements s'en préoccupe depuis
longtemps évidemment avec un degré
variable s'est plus prononcé au parti
québécois ou à callelongue coalition
bois québec de se lier au parti libéral
mais ça reste une préoccupation pour
tout le monde donc à la compo position
de l'émigration est une chose comme on
les reçoit aussi mis les raisons c'est
des cons on peut très bien décider de
mettre le paquet en francisation si on
veut on peut y mettre les millions on a
l'argent on est capable de le faire si
on le souhaite on peut être capable de
dire on va prendre un travailleur
qualifie puis on voit le pays pour
suivre des cours de français et on va
l'intégrer au travail c'est un choix
aussi c'est pas uniquement dans le
nombre dans la manière dont les reçoit
la composition l'immigration à la base
le chiffre ce n'est qu'une composante
peut-être tape-à-l'oeil assez facile
mais il ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de subtilité notamment la
régionalisation de l'immigration tout le
monde
faudrait que les immigrants s'installer
en région certains partie des 50% les
migrants le sait pas des numéros on peut
dire à vous allez travailler en abitibi
vous allez travailler sur la côte-nord
site où ils ont le droit de se déplacer
la terre du territoire après des
incitatifs pour qu'il reste en région
dont une composition
s'étendent aussi beaucoup plus complexe
que seulement un chiffre là pour les
différents partis bon michel
je vous retrouve d'abord sur les jeux
vous demandez la philosophie derrière
shrek et on voit quand même deux grandes
offres l'hôte et les gens qui veulent
réduire au nom du français d'autres qui
disent on n'a pas le choix d'augmenter
au nom de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
mais ont volé on va leur apprendre le
français dans qu'est ce que tu fais
réconcilia
serait conciliables si on met les liens
internes et des ressources à la
francisation ce qu'on n'a pas toujours
fait souvenez-vous qu'un monsieur
bouchard avait coupé un peu partout pour
était de 7,0 première chose qui a passé
dans le tordeur seller koffi et semble
dominante actions de formation des
clients qui étaient menacés bon succès
de prat isation l'époque on n'a pas
toujours été conséquent d'autre part il
ya plein d'autres facteurs aujourd'hui
moi j'étais très surpris par exemple sur
l'euro dire oui on va prendre moins d'un
miracle avec ceux du canada donc pro
politique du québec
monsieur bourassa faisait une obsession
du poids politique du québec au canada
et avait fait inscrire la corde qu'on
arrive à avoir toujours 25 % des
immigrants au canada et ce aussi pour en
parler parce que ça fait partie du
dossier il ya vraiment plusieurs couches
lait
j'ai posé la question à monsieur le
gruyère exactement ça sur le le poids
relatif du québec il faut comprendre que
le canada est parmi les pays sur la
planète qui va accueillir en 2023 le
plus d'immigrants on est à
4,445 mais la cible alors évidemment si
nous si au québec il baisse à 50 milles
d'ici 10-15 ans le poids relatif du
québec va baisser la note la population
du québec va augmenter moins rapidement
que celles du reste du canada bon alex
est ce que c'est une préoccupation sur
le go à 10 aujourd'hui
regardez la suite sur pas très nombreux
mais sont heureux en voulant dire ben on
va être moins ou être moins nombreux
mais on va être plus francophone si si
le sous texte là
la réalité c'est même avec des cibles du
parti libéral du québec le poids du
québec dans le canada va diminuer parce
que la machine étatique canadienne
décider lequel mettait la [ __ ] au fond
on va être rendu à plus de 450 milles en
2024 par année le québec ne vaut pas
accueillir 100 1000 immigrants par année
pour maintenir son poids dans le canada
ce serait impossible impossible sur le
plan linguistique impossible sur le plan
aussi de d'autres facteurs la crise du
logement faut toujours bien que les gens
arrivent ici avec un logement décent et
là on a des difficultés à avoir des
logements décents dans la plupart des
régions du québec alors le choix que le
gouvernement fédéral au fait ils
compteraient le québec avoir une
diminution de son prêt à discuter de
cela avec leur avec le gouvernement
canadien on pourrait décider d'en faire
un débat politique on pourrait amener ça
sort là la place publique en disant vous
attendez un peu là ça n'a pas de bon
sens que vous êtes entraîneur et je
pense les répéteurs des provinces
respectives à ce type de débat là on
passe notarié ou trouve qu'ils en
reçoivent beaucoup soit dit en passant
et c'est tout une adaptation à pour ces
personnes-là mais actuellement les aucun
des partis politiques qui dans sa
politique d'émigration permet de garder
le produit québec dans la fédération
autour du 23 mai
emilie a donc deux planètes
dans le domaine de l'immigration avec le
dit même si le seuil devait monter à 70
75 le québec ne sera n'accueillera pas
autant que
objectif canadien qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ça mais c'est parce qu'il ya
deux choses différentes donc on mélange
souvent le poids du québec dans le
canada qui est le poids des francophones
ou de la langue française au canada puis
la langue française c'est plus que le
québec puisqu'on voit avec la politique
d'immigration
jusqu'à maintenant ça fait des années
que la fédération des communautés
francophones et acadiennes demande que
dans les taux fédéraux des migrations
une plus grande partie des migrants
francophones soient choisis par le
fédéral et ça c'est une demande que ça
fait des années qu'ils ne durent pas au
fédéral et c'est ce qui fait aussi
beaucoup diminué la part du français
dans un canada c'est la manque de
responsabilité d'ottawa dans le choix
des uns qui vont partout dans les
provinces canadiennes fait diminuer le
poids des communautés francophones donc
quand on regarde la proportion du québec
dans l'ensemble du canada ça diminue
dont donc le français diminuent
l'équation est possible thématiques que
ça elle est plus comme ça en ce moment
parce que le gouvernement fédéral
responsable à ce niveau là et moi
j'aimerais s'entend des partis
politiques honnêtement province à se
prononcer là dessus pour moi c'est l'un
des deux l'éléphant dans la pièce du
débat dans l'immigration de la langue
française est en ce moment dans la
manière dont on en discute au québec
mais oublions du second doublions jamais
mais oublions du second de la langue
française le poids démographique
si le québec accueille moins il va il va
il va diminuer oui
merci sûr c'est sûr absolument puis
quand j'entends par exemple la carte
soit évité la question ou dire aux côtés
de spalletti partis politiques dits en
conséquence qu'on va passer bloquer le
nombre de sièges que le québec à la
chambre des communes on se retrouve dans
une revendication qui de fait même mine
de la notion de démocratie
représentative
c'est sûr que son cerveau là dedans on
risque d'avoir à des problèmes avec les
provinces donc je pense pas que pour un
enfant des raisons elle s'assoit une
voix qui vont mener à l'harmonie dans la
fédération je tombe vous est emilie a
clairement on devrait suivre le reste
c'est ce que vous sous tendent et là
je dis que le rythme on devrait en
parler mais je dis que quand le québec
parle
décide que c'est l'immigration doivent
baisser puis qu'on a fait comme si la
question
n'avait pas de conséquence on se met le
doigt dans l'oeil je pense qu'on doit
assumer les conséquences de nos choix
c'est ça ou simplement mais michel on
peut enfin d'aujourd'hui d'hier on va
assumer mais on peut pas suivre le
rythme c'est en deux mots c'est ce qu'il
en veut on peut pas suivre le rythme
mais en même temps est-ce que un produit
du québec peut dire un jour un jour qui
n'est pas loin
jouvet bas on va être à peu près avait
pour sa du propos une tique du canada
c'est pas grave ça j'ai plus de
difficulté j'ai je comprends l'argument
monsieur legault il est défendable on
peut être d'accord pas d'accord les
plusieurs religions là dessus ça c'est
correct mais à un moment donné le
premier du québec est aussi le garant
politique du québec au sein du canada
le polo et il ya des questions ça
beaucoup causer un débat beaucoup plus
large et des questions beaucoup plus
large que juste le nom est combat et
comment on les fera aussi c'est quelque
chose de votre réseau plus large
réalisée patron pour avoir un débat peut
laisser indifférent on pourrait décider
éventuellement le soumettons conroux la
constitution la maîtrise
suivez moi ça va prendre jusqu'à cinq
ans l'alberta
est ce que ça se négocie politiquement
de dire en tant que peuples fondateurs
et en tant que nation francophone en
amérique du nord et de rechutes richesse
pour la canada on va toujours avoir 23 %
des sièges à la chambre des communes peu
importe notre poids politique
nous on a besoin d'attaquer moins
d'immigrants pour garder la langue
française en vie respectez ça on va
négocier un plan un plancher de
pourcentage et non pas de siège pour
qu'éventuellement on peut savoir ce
débat là c'est faisable encore
faudrait-il vouloir avoir sa démo losc
est une autre question mais c'est
faisable et des arguments autour de
cette question là qu'on pourrait
mais on n'en est pas là je suis
actuellement peut-être que ça va être
obligatoire comme discussions mais c'est
un type très bien effectivement parce
que ça amène logiquement
monsieur legault ça peut la mener
logiquement dire mais dans un monde
idéal où il n'ya pas de contraintes qui
a pas de sondages a pas de nos potes de
60 % québécois qui veulent pas de
référendum dans un monde idéal
logiquement ça nous mène à la
souveraineté parce qu'on se décrochent
d'une logique canadienne je vais je vais
vous faire entendre monsieur legault
talent et qu'on pense que je vais
garder la suisse petit pays
extraordinairement riche
extraordinairement dynamique prenez des
pays scandinaves petit pays extrêmement
riche extrêmement dynamique est gros ça
peut effectivement être beau mais ce qui
est important c'est d'avoir une qualité
de vie pour les personnes qui habitent
au québec
donc c'est la logique mais chassez
commenter ce que vous venez d'entendre
c'est la logique de la qualité de vie
mais c'est pas la logique de génération
dans lequel québec se trouvent et qui
est parfois et qui demandent des choses
différentes du reste du canada
le gardien de la francophonie canadienne
si elle n'a pas de québec qui est bon il
est vrai de la francophonie
alors ça c'est un rôle qui rôle du
premier ministre du québec de dire je
m'occupe de tout ça et je pense pas sûr
que dans la façon dont il joue ses pions
sur les questions de décès et
d'immigration et tout ça juste une
question prospérité sont entourées comme
une suite de mots bien aimé que ça ne
joue pas au détriment du québec dans
l'ensemble canadien et monsieur leubou
après il a décidé qu'il était plus
souverainiste il n'y a pas l'air d'avoir
compris que devait jouer un rôle dans la
fédération aussi et ça c'est à ce stade
il va falloir
mais emilie c'est intéressant aussi
parce qu'on peut poser la question là
comme je voulais ce fait je fais deux
fois je voulais mais on peut poser la
question est ce que le québec doit peut
suivre le rythme d'accueil de
l'immigration que le reste du canada
décidé de faire c'est une question qui
se pose quand même billy
qu'elles sont qui se passe mais je pense
que la question qui se pose en arrière
de ce qu'on est au centre et enfin ne
peut en prend pour acquis le sait que la
manière de faire rayonner la langue
française c'est d'avoir du respect on va
dire pour ça pour la différence
québécoise
c'est la force du non on prend ça pour
acquis qu'on est dans un système
politique ce n'est pas le nombre ne pas
le respect donc là on est en train de se
dire comment est ce qu'on fait pour
garder normes sont par la norme par le
respect alors qu'il ya d'autres
philosophies politiques on se dit baye
le respect c'est pour tout le monde
c'est pas normal qu'ils sont donc fermés
une question de majorité donc là quand
je pense que quand on se met à réfléchir
comme ça aussi on voit différentes
avenues aussi pour pour le québec qui
ironiquement mais je pense que
ironiquement au sens où je pense que
c'est ce à quoi monsieur legault pense
qu'andy sommet quand il parle de pays
d'europe on voit bien que en fait c'est
pas nous ferment le nombre qui fait la
force puis je pense que c'est pas
nécessairement comme ça qu'on a
l'habitude de réfléchir se débloquer
mais pour ceux qui
n'ont
plus vraiment et associations repart
depuis le début
3 est ce que nous allons jouer notre jeu
troisième lien et muriel qui regardent
québec deux audi monsieur legault y est
je vous présente un extrait de cette
émission qu'on a présenté hier sur le
troisième bien et on revient tout de
suite
quand on tient compte de la population
des projections des prochaines années on
a besoin d'un troisième lié à québec
faut que les gens montréal arrête de
regarder de haut les gens québec et de
lévis
céline vous parlez du troisième lien
aurait voulu être les gens de montréal
et c'est ce qui aiderait les gens de
tout le québec monsieur legault c'est si
on avait des chiffres sur la table d'ici
le 3 octobre vous vous engagez à déposer
ce que vous avez comme études non loin
c'est dépassé avec lacan et demi mais
avec la pandémie il ya beaucoup plus de
monde qui font du télétravail
donc les chiffres doivent être mis à
jour on ne peut pas forcer des chiffres
qui ne sont plus gros
donc deux choses un volet plus politique
sur le go qui dit arrêtez les
montréalais de nous garder de regarder
québec de haut et en
parlant beaucoup à sion d'électeurs de
la région de québec en envoyez-vous
emilie vous êtes de lévis et
logeant qui fait des études mais
commençons par le montréal québec
est-ce qu'il renvoie pas refaire être
cette rivalité montréal québec émilie
comment vous avez trouvé cette remarque
de monsieur legault
imagine que les gens montréal sont des
death note philippe hui que les gens du
plateau mont royal l'ex de kylie qui
regarde le nombre de haut c'est drôle
parce que justement je me souviens en
grandissant dans la région québec selon
l'entente tout le temps puis avant même
d'avoir passé du temps à montréal je
savais que ça maintenant existé avait
déjà être mystérieux ce plateau mont
royal qui nous prenait l'eau donc c'est
intéressant
que traverser de l'autre côté du miroir
dont je cherche encore ses mots cela
dans mon quartier mais je pense que ça
fera pas un imaginaire quand il dit des
choses comme ça c'est sûr que ça déplaît
pour montréal lorsqu'il est question
d'avoir des votes mais ce qui est sûr je
retiens surtout les chantres garçon sait
que c'est que la cac est en train de
dire que les sensibilités montréal et un
autre que moi j'ai pas attendu sur un
autre dossier de ce qui se passe à
montréal donc une sensibilité des
montréalais sont échoués
on va y revenir à montréal québec et
aussi aux fameuses études qui sont
dépassés dit monsieur legault le ciel
sont dépassés quelles études montrent qu
on a vraiment besoin de ce lien soit peu
sur la question composaient
mais je vous dis merci on va aller au
point de presse tout de suite la grc la
saskatchewan semana blackmore qui parle
et il y aurait du nouveau donc suite à
cette tuerie
merci peut-être on se revoit peut-être
pas merci